there are brand new allegations against
tsm owner reginald of him being a
volatile ceo who created a toxic
workplace former tsm player doublelift
has spoken up to say that reginald
threatened to sue him for allegations he
publicly made last year it's the latest
chapter in a deepening controversy
here's all the details
all right there's a very good chance
that you're familiar with the previous
videos we've made on this subject but if
you're not here's a quick refresh
doublelift spent a number of years as
tsm's a.d carry on their league of
legends team helping them to multiple
lcs titles in november 2021 he was
involved in a public war of words with
tsm's owner reginald over the
circumstances of his departure from the
team the year before doublelift had said
that he wanted to keep playing for the
team especially with star support sword
art but that reginald refused because he
had quote too much of an ego reginald
hit back with a reddit post disputing
doublelift's account claiming that
doublelift was quote upset because we
weren't interested in working with him
and then the floodgates opened people
don't like working with them it's funny
that he has his holier than that
attitude about it because
he's like a bully who gets away with
being a bad person
because he's powerful because people are
afraid to stand up to him and that's
what i'm sick of so i would just say
that he made a lot of players cry you'd
be very [ __ ] surprised
at how many of maybe your favorite
familiar faces in lcs legit mental
breakdown because of how badly
they've been getting berated how badly
they were just getting verbally
assaulted this wasn't the first time
that accusations against reginald's
conduct have been made clips resurfaced
of old exchanges from the early days of
tsm between reginald and former players
that were used by people to back up
doublelift's claims
it feels like like you're just trying to
put it all in turtle no i'm not putting
it all into it no you are putting it on
turtle
okay
yeah
oh yeah you are yeah yeah
okay yeah i know that but so do you say
why are you arguing with me about it
it's so true though in january this year
wyatt published their investigation into
the matter including a statement from
riot that they were aware of the
allegations and had launched an
independent investigation into the
claims they also shared anonymous
accounts from former tsm staff claiming
they have been subjected to mental abuse
by reginald and that they've been
dominated by a culture of fear at tsm in
which he called them stupid or worthless
and called them after work at times to
scream at them tsm also announced they'd
be conducting their own internal
investigation
it's the findings of these two
investigations that the community has
been waiting on this week we didn't get
those findings but we did get something
else on wednesday the washington post
mikhail clementoff published an article
detailing the termination of a former
head of human resources for tsm weeks
after his hiring the hr head was
allegedly fired over a recruitment
practice he wanted to implement when an
employee asked reginald what prompted
the firing the source said quote that
was when andy told the whole company
that the hr person was let go because he
asked a question that andy didn't like i
think he kind of realized how ridiculous
it sounded so he followed up by saying
well he asked two questions that i
didn't like the article also quoted
anthony barnes a former senior program
manager at blitz the desktop gaming app
owned by tsm he said quote nobody wanted
to be in a one-on-one meeting with andy
because you had no witnesses i mean that
literally who knew if andy was going to
scream or yell at you degrade you be
friendly or just be confused or
inquisitive you weren't sure what andy
you were going to get but the more
people on the call the more likely andy
wasn't going to be a complete volcano
the report also detailed that multiple
workers at tsm and blitz have been
misclassified as contractors rather than
full-time employees this is a key
distinction under labour laws because it
dictates how workers are paid what
benefits they receive and what legal
rights they have a misclassification
could be a serious breach by any company
tsm told the washington post that they
would not be commenting on any
misclassification complaints the report
also shared stories of former tsm and
blitz employees experiences at their
companies these included allegations of
contractors being expected to work 40
hours a week and show up for work at 9
00 am all being paid below the legal
annual minimum for contract work in
california aside from that there was
also an account of reginald calling
individuals or teams out in public work
channels for work that he found is
satisfactory one former blitz employee
recounted that after tsm's ballarant
squad lost in 2020's first strike
tournament reginald joined work calls to
quote ream and tear down employees and
that they felt like they were quote
being hunted that day tsm reiterated two
comments to the washington post that
they've made to wired in january this
year firstly that they would not be
commenting on the allegations against
reginald until they'd concluded their
own internal investigation and secondly
a statement from reginald in which he
described his nature as intense
passionate and driven and that if he
feels someone is not delivering he
shares feedback bluntly and directly he
also said again that looking back his
vocabulary was too harsh at times and
that he knows he needs to work on his
delivery reginald replied to the article
in the tsm subreddit explaining that he
was not the direct manager of the head
of hr who was let go he said they had
disagreed on the proposal plan of
recruiting from another company in order
to build strong relationships with them
reginald disagreed saying the other
company was a competitor and that the
proposal showed a lack of prioritization
for these reasons he thought it would be
best to part ways sooner rather than
later the comment was down voted well
over a hundred times and many people in
the comments were calling reginald out
for not addressing the rest of the
article on wednesday doublelift reacted
to reginald's reddit comment on stream
and said that reginald had tried to sue
him for comments that he made last year
he's sitting there crying he's so
furious he's talking to stories like
what can i do man how
dude how can i get this guy to stop
talking about me yeah i still i still
have the letter of when he he threatened
to sue me for the first time dude it's
it's so insanely crazy it's it's like i
called him out for being a bully who
silences like the voices of his like
underlings and then he tries to threaten
to sue me
for disparaging his company the
following day doublelift shared the
letter he received from tsm lawyers a
few days after his stream in november
2021 it stated that the comments made by
doublelift then constituted multiple
material and incurable breaches of his
employment agreement with tsm they
claimed he shared confidential
information that breached both his
employment and release agreement and
that he went against both agreements to
not disparage or make defamatory and
unprofessional remarks against tsm or
any affiliates business structures
operations practices or management the
letter finished by stating that tsm
would be evaluating each breach and
exploring its legal options they listed
liquidated damages of one hundred
thousand dollars for each breach of the
employment agreement and two hundred
thousand dollars for each breach of the
release agreement doublelift had shared
the letter on stream the day before
releasing it on twitter and far from
being intimidated by it he felt it
helped his cause
let me just tell you guys that this
whole thing just completely plays into
the
uh idea that andy is a huge bully and
that he can get away with he wants
because he's powerful
it's so funny that it just like
completely proves my point doublelift
presented the papers as an attempt to
sue him i spoke to our in-house legal
counsel who said that these papers are a
cease-and-desist and contract
termination letter tsm state they are
evaluating the alleged breaches and
intend to pursue legal action i.e suing
to recover damages from doublelift
moving now from the legal world to the
court of public opinion things couldn't
get much worse for reginald right now
he's being slammed yet again within the
community after another scathing article
which alleges toxic bullying treatment
of his employees his attempt to explain
the initial accusation of the article in
tsm's own subreddit has been downvoted
and piled on by both tsm fans and the
wider community and to top it all off
doublelift has called him out again as
he has done at every step of this story
we still don't know when the findings of
riot's investigation will be published
but one thing is for sure when they are
it will be monumental if they find him
to be innocent or are seen to be being
too lenient with him they could be
accused of cowing to the influence that
tsm has as a major brand within the lcs
if they come down on him like a ton of
bricks i don't think it's an
exaggeration to say it could set a
precedent for the north american scene
the wider league scene in general and
perhaps even esports the world over so
we await the report and if anything
happens before then we'll be sure to let
you know
you